these personal connections have
developed over years you know with
uh woody and joey gallo and then of
course with chris young being teammates
with ian kennedy none of this was a very
easy decision for anyone in the front
office but
we saw the rangers make some pretty
significant moves before the season even
started and then of course the deadline
today
the era has gone up here in the second
half went into
the all-star break with the zra right
around a 369.
he gets that one right in there for a
called third strike
on crawford and that is how we get
started tonight
[Applause]
well be all for not as a ground ball to
shortstop will end the inning
and the mariners leave a couple so it is
a scoreless first
for allard and now the rangers come to
back this is a starting lineup that
logan gilbert should be able to go right
after he's making his 13th start of the
season
4-2 record at 381 era for
welcome gilbert another 2-2
outer black paint and that is strikeout
number one logan gilbert punches out the
first man that he faces
strike three call gas once again
a couple of strikeouts out of the gates
both looking facing adolescera quickly
ahead on two
swing and a miss a righty 96 mile an
hour heater
logan gilbert strikes out the side in
order
lashed into right field and short
hopping the wall
toro is into second base
he stands up a leadoff double
he pulls this breaking ball into right
field toro
is being held at third left on left base
hit for jared kelnick
after falling behind the mariners have
them loaded up
here's dylan moore with the bases loaded
bases loaded walk they appealed on a
check swing
he does not go already three walks in
the ball game for the mariners
villamora pick up an rbi jp look for him
to be aggressive here
big chop off the plate connor palefah
onto first base in time murphy's scores
that's a two-nothing mariners lead anger
with the base hit his first time up
on the ground hard hit gobbled up connor
philippa coming home wide
throw koenig is safe meanwhile right on
his heels here is dylan moore
as that throw gets away the mariners
cash it in for two
they've doubled the lead it's four
nothing and he thought he had a play at
the plate but his
throw was wide bounced it up there gets
away from hyman a little more paying
attention able to score
one two pitch swinging in the miss he
struck him out on a high fastball
so ty france is out of there he wants
two in the set and he's one three in
total tonight facing terrence
both the walks in the second score he
rips this out to the gap at left center
field
off the very top of the wall out of
bounds
it's another extra base hit for the
mariners terenza's lead off stand-up
double
counter falefa pumps a fastball to first
base not in time
toro lags it out he's showing off some
tools tonight
ropes a double earlier now an infield
base hit
it's a good pitch from colby strikes out
murphy
his third strikeout for the ball game
here comes jared kellnick who's one for
one
crushed walloped and goodbye
what a shot jared kelnett blowing it
wide open in the third a three-run
tater kalnik's third of the show seven
nothing mariners now that was squared up
takes that back to the glove there's
strikeout number four
for logan gilbert just off the corner
gets him to chase it
swing and a miss another good heater he
has struck out
five of the first nine rangers batters
that he's faced
a lot of life to his heater this evening
and he's using it 95 96 miles an hour
been pretty consistent there
murphy sets up away for the o2
seeger has it routinely at third
three up three down as logan gilbert's
faced one over the minimum through three
scoreless
he smashes that one down the third
baseline
karim's right out into left field for
more
and adolescent easy one out double in
the fourth inning
here's low
this one right up the middle that's a
base hit for low
garcia heads to the plate he scores
and the rangers are on the board low
with his second hit of the ball game and
he makes it
7-1
this ball belted out to right field
that'll get down
bounce off the fence terry chugging into
third base
on the jason martin double oh walk and a
two base hit and the rangers have a
couple of men in scoring position
well believe it or not that's jason
martin's first double of
the season counter falafel has trucked
out and ground it out
uh this one rolled up the middle i don't
get a run home
crawford's sort of first in time and
they get kinder pulapa
and they're two away
[Applause]
and he went right after 95 right down
the middle swinging a miss struck him
out
six strikeouts for logan gilbert the
rangers in the fifth pick up a run
andolis garcia facing logan gilbert
who's thrown 77 pitches through five
and that ball smoked hit deep out to
left it
is gone into the second deck out in left
field
and el bombie is back it's been a while
but that's a big home run
for garcia makes it seven to three
jonah heim over two he's flat out and
grounded out this will be gilbert's 90th
pitch of the night
and it is hit hard deep out to right
gone jonah his fifth home run of the
year
it's 7-4 scott's going to his pen
logan one out away from going a full six
massage is
coming in to record the final out of the
sixth inning
swing and a miss for a strike three
missevich makes quick work at david dahl
to complete the six
ripped down to the corner and a fair
ball
[Applause]
france making his way into second base
he's got a lead-off double
there comes kyle seeger he's over two
with a
pulled walk the right side for a base
hit france is coming home
here's the throw to the plate and france
is safe with a slide as the throw goes
up the line
seeger wasted no time it's an 8-4
mariners lead brings jason martin
to the plate this phone belted out to
center field
really well struck and it is gone jason
martin straight away center field
and it's an eight to five ball game just
his second
career home run
that rides high a couple of walks
scores throwing hard
he's not locating it 2-1
and this one lined out to right field
and dahl
gets to it on a slide and that is the
first down of the inning well that was
close
all right initial concern there was that
one was going to get down and then
become a whole lot of trouble
ground ball up the middle diving clanks
off the glove of ibanez a flip to second
and safe there terrence everybody's safe
all the way around
brett martin now is up on the mound as
spores
face four batters walk the couple of
them and exits after
recording just one out
on the falafel ground balance throw of
bones
they get murphy at second seeger scores
lead off walk comes all the way around
9-5 mariners
here we go bottom nine mariners 9-5 lead
the mariner debut of the new closure
diego castillo
on the ground j.p crawford gobbles it up
castillo and his mariner's debut retires
the sign in order
and closes the door on a mariners game
one win nine to five the final score
nice way to start the road trip we
thought these games were going to be
important before they head off
to tampa and new york nice to get the
first one